und von bist jetzt endlich daheim was
kann ich dafür das Meeting hat doch
länger gedauert dann geht doch selber
einkaufen sind doch deine Eltern die zum
Abendessen kommen überleg du dir doch
was ihr zum Schmorbraten machen ich bin
noch nicht deine Moment ich habe da
vielleicht was
[Musik]
Entschuldigung sind Sie hier für die
Kartoffeln zuständig Kartoffeln
Kartoffeln von mir aus wie viel kostet
denn das Kilo ein Kilo Kartoffeln 8 Euro
8 Euro und also nicht gerade ein
Schnäppchen aber okay wenn sie frisch
sind und wir die frisch sein zu
Frühstück Kartoffeln hast du nur den
Kopf na gut aber sind die denn auch
sauber diese Kartoffeln ich will ja
nicht dass sie mir mein Cabrio verdecken
mit dem Zahnbürste
im Frischhaltefolie verpackt
gut whatever ich nehme dann mal fünf
Kilo 5 Kilo Kartoffeln wunderbar
[Musik]
der letzte Bauer darf ich hier
Kartoffeln pflücken das ist ja Wahnsinn
du kannst jetzt mit deine stiefel-schuhe
da einfacher Bäume auf und abgehen dann
kriegst Prozente
[Musik]
[Applaus]